oui
[Musique]
je
sur les mineurs nous recevons dans notre
émission le directeur général du centre
chinois de contrôle des maladies le
professeur à george xiao qui nous a
rejoint de la chine
merci d'être avec nous je dois rappeler
que sur ces deux millions de morts
le royaume uni serait le pays le plus
touché on procède à la vaccination
nous sommes à l'avant-garde de la
campagne de vaccination massive contre
le corona virus pourquoi êtes vous
préoccupé par les vaccins qui sont
actuellement disponibles sur le marché
je ne pense pas être préoccupé par les
vaccins et vous savez pour ce qui est
des vaccins on peut dire que c'est la
seule arme avec laquelle nous allons
éradiquer les virus ou du type d'agents
pathogènes donc pour le vaccin je ne
suis pas un truc pour ce qui est du côté
de 19
c'est la première fois que l'humanité à
élaborer un vaccin contre le corps
navires us et tout le monde sait il y a
beaucoup d'inconnues pour ce virus donc
comme il ya énormément d'inconnus et que
nous voulons voir à un vaccin être
injectés à la population considérait
comme scène
nous sommes inquiets pour est il oui ou
non y avoir des effets indésirables
voilà pourquoi tout le monde est inquiet
cependant si vous demandez pourquoi tu
as fait cela c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
d'autre choix
nous vivons tous sur cette planète nous
travaillons également très dur on essaie
de trouver un équilibre bénéfice risque
oui notre analyse montre que la
vaccination est une meilleure solution
que de prendre le risque d'être infecté
par le codis 19 il n'y a pas d'immunité
collectif dans le monde entier
le virus a la possibilité de monter et
on a déjà cinq ou six variant sexe sans
contention immunitaire le virus
continuera de muter c'est ça qui nous
inquiète donc en général qui nous
devrions prendre ce risque
s'il ya un risque quelconque liés à la
vaccination plutôt que d'attendre nous
deux
plus attendre vous voulez dire que vos
commentaires concernant votre inquiétude
sur le vaccin de pfizer ont été exagérés
dans les médias il n'y a aucune preuve
que les décès en norvège serait
directement lié au vaccin à l'agent arn
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'il a été dit que
vous étiez préoccupé par ce type de
vaccin parce que c'est la première fois
que l'agent arn est introduit dans le
corps humain
donc nous ne savons pas ce qui va se
produire la technologie actuelle nous
dit que ça fonctionne mais pour être
honnête
vu que c'est la première fois qu'on fait
cela une population de seine
je dis qu'il faut faire attention
du reste nous devrions tous nous faire
vacciner
comment peut-on expliquer les taux
d'efficacité très différent des divers
vaccins proposés kraiser revendiqua
vaccin efficace à plus de 90% pour
sinovac ekoro novak c'est seulement 54%
selon les essais brésilien eh bien je
pense que toutes ces expériences ont été
menées en très peu quand il y assez de
temps la fabrication de tout vaccin
devrait prendre environ une décennie
quelques années mais cette fois ci moins
d'un an je l'ait déjà évoquée mais je le
répète encore une fois c'est une
question de rapport bénéfice risque nous
devons prendre ce risque
et vous avez personnellement pris ce
risque
pourquoi vous êtes-vous fait inoculer un
vaccin expérimental si tôt avant même
laissé en double aveugle et bien vous
savez parce que je suis un professionnel
je j'ai d'abord été formé comme
vétérinaire
j'écris beaucoup de vaccins vétérinaires
quant à la façon dont nous avons
fabriquer le vaccin
nous avons développé beaucoup de lignes
technologique pour les vaccins je crois
que toutes ses lignes sont suffisamment
bonnes pour qu'on puisse prendre ce
risque
si je ne prends pas ce risque comment
puis-je persuader les gens comment leur
faire croire qu'il y a une chance de
vaincre le virus
la vaccination implique plus de
mutations car les variants qui survivent
à la vaccination prospère quelle est
votre opinion sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
compte tenu du nombre de mutations qui
ont eu lieu la mutation britannique
celle du brésil celle de l'afrique du
sud
ah ça on ne peut pas savoir
la littérature scientifique actuelle
nous dit que pour le moment
avec toutes ces mutations il pourrait y
avoir un petit effet je ne vois rien qui
pourrait laisser penser qu'il y ait un
très grand effet
selon les études actuelles bien sûr si
vous êtes immunisés cela peut pousser le
virus a muté
mais une fois que vous serez immunisés
par vaccination le virus n'aura aucune
chance de survivre et de se transmettre
entre humains le centre chinois de
contrôle des maladies n'a pas encore
testé son vaccin sinovac sur le varia
britanniques qu'à une capacité de
transmission beaucoup plus élevé
l'augmentation du taux de transmission
est en fait pire pour l'humanité que le
taux élevé de mortalité
c'est beaucoup plus dangereux le vaccin
chinois est il efficace contre le
coronavirus britannique
je pense que c'est la chose sur laquelle
nous travaillons nous n'avons pas encore
de résultats ça ressemble à un disney à
tom et jerry une fois que les virus
apparaissent ils essaient de survivre
et s'ils veulent essayer de survivre ils
doivent lutter trouver un moyen de se
transformer pour s'assurer de survivre
mais ils ne peuvent pas devenir plus
meurtrier pour les êtres humains
sinon s'il tue tous ces autres comment
le virus peut-il survivre
il ya donc une stratégie du virus visant
à assurer sa survie dans la population
humaine
demain se fera un an que le premier cas
a été signalé aux états unis à quand
remontent les cas d'infections
coronavirus avant cette date
le cobp et 19 a été détecté à one si je
me trompe pas le 17 novembre 2019 le
south china morning post a publié ces
informations en disant qu'il y avait eu
un cas d'infection dans la province du
haut by quand le virus est il apparu en
chine pour la première fois je sais que
des représentants de l'om est se trouve
à one en ce moment
nous avons isolé le virus début janvier
avec mon collègue du cdc nous avons
travaillé très dur nous avons obtenu le
virus tôt le matin dans la nuit des 6 et
7 janvier et nous avons travaillé jour
et nuit
c'est la première fois que nous avons vu
à quoi a ressemblé le virus grâce à une
nouvelle technologie
donc nous avons séquencé le génome
complet du virus et nous y sommes
arrivés en une semaine
bien sûr si vous voulez en discuter plus
en détail nous pouvons revenir au début
rétrospectivement peut-être qu'en chine
nous avions déjà vu des patients des cas
suspects mais cela n'a pas été confirmé
nous avons toujours beaucoup de maladies
respiratoires aiguës graves
le strass par exemple il y attend deux
cas chaque année
r3 grippe il existe tant le virus je
pense que pendant environ un mois deux
semaines les médecins ont probablement
remarqué la chose mais il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de groupes ou de clusters à
l'époque est soudainement fin 2019
alors on nous a appelés et nous sommes
allés sur le terrain nous avons
recueilli toutes ces données et nous
avons finalement compris que c'était un
coronavirus nous avons partagé les
données elle était déjà disponible le 10
janvier
c'est le centre clinique de santé
publique de shanghai qui a publié
l'information sur le génome
non cela a été fait avec le gie seuils
de l'initiative mondiale sur le partage
de données sur la grippe aviaire et
publié par le cdc de chine l'institut de
virologie l'académie chinoise des
sciences et l'académie chinoise des
sciences médicales mais vous pouvez
aller consulter le site du 17 ça a été
fait le 10 janvier il a été annoncé ici
que le centre clinique de santé publique
de shanghai avait publié des
informations sur le génome qui était en
quelque sorte confidentielles c'est ce
que la presse dit à ce sujet eh bien
vous savez beaucoup de rumeurs circulent
il y a beaucoup de choses différentes de
ce qu'on a ici aller consulter le site
demandé à pfizer et biotech
ils ont développé le vaccin allez
vérifier avec eux où ils ont obtenu la
séquence pour synthétiser le gène et
leurs vaccins à arn je pense que c'est
très clair ils affirment dans leur
publication dans le new england journal
of medicine à voir et télécharger les
séquences depuis le style dj c'est le ji
said est un projet international visant
à partager les données avec tous nos
amis le disent aide est une organisation
pour que tout le monde partage ses
données sur le virus de la grippe moi
même avec le fondateur de cette
organisation
nous avons envoyé la séquence dans leur
base de données pour le partager avec le
monde chez si vous avez des doutes
demandez à ceux qui ont développé le
vaccin de pfizer
nous avons commencé notre conversation
sur le vaccin de pfizer et le monde en
est reconnaissant il y a beaucoup de
rumeurs qui circulent comme vous le
savez que pensez-vous de mac pompéo le
secrétaire d'état de donald trump qui a
fait des déclarations sur le laboratoire
de one ils ont évoqué quelque chose
appelée le et raté g13 qui est une
souche du corona virus dont le génome
est proche du comas 19
que pouvez vous dire à propos des
affirmations du département d'état
américain de l'administration trump
selon lesquelles il y avait des
expériences sur un virus de type
coronavirus avant même que l' oms
annonce l'apparition du corona virus
je pense qu'il y ait un jour différents
arguments quant à savoir s'il faut
travailler ou non sur le virus et
combien de temps les scientifiques
devraient travailler dessus alors
pouvons-nous synthétiser le virus
prenons par exemple le virus de la
grippe de 1918 après le séquençage du
génome le virus a été re synthétiser
nous avons le virus vivants de
l'épidémie de 1918
nous ne l'avions pas isolé auparavant
mais nous l'avons synthétiser in vitro
qui techniquement sous strict contrôle
réglementaire de biosécurité vous pouvez
mais c'est toujours à débattre quant aux
et raté g13
c'est un virus c'est un génome il est
spécifique à la chauve souris
personne n'a jamais développé ce virus
personne ne peut cultiver les virus vous
ne pouvez pas cultiver la plupart des
virus de chauves souris
il n'y a pas de virus vivants de ra tj
13 vous comprenez nous sommes toujours
limité par notre cerveau notre
expérience nous pensons que nous pouvons
nous fondée sur le bon sens se baser sur
nos connaissances tirer des leçons de
certaines données scientifiques que nous
connaissons mais en fin de compte
regardez ce à quoi nous sommes
confrontés avec le colis de 19 à mon
avis après un an il n'y aura peut-être
pas d'autres intermédiaires ou d'autres
réservoirs
c'est une question scientifique
le président 19 c'est le co vite 19 on
dirait qu'il ne suit pas les règles que
nous avons apprises de notre bon sens ou
de notre expérience et c'est pourquoi je
pense qu'il faut laisser la question de
l'origine et de l'évolution du
coronavirus aux scientifiques déjà bien
sûr ce ne sont pas des scientifiques
mais des hommes politiques en ont parlé
est ce une résurgence de la guerre
froide quand mike pompéo déclare que
l'institut de guan mener des expériences
la presse parlait ici d'un journaliste
zong ans en prison pour avoir diffusé
des informations sur l'épidémie diwan
toutes ces histoires au sein des pays de
l'otan voyez vous cela comme une
politisation du coronavirus dès le début
de cette épidémie
j'ai moi-même été attaqués et tony faut
si le célèbre monologue a été attaqué
dans de jean robert et de field aussi le
directeur général américain du cdc a été
attaqué beaucoup de scientifiques ont
fait l'objet d'attaqués
c'est à cause de l'info d'énigmes fatah
mais l'info d'amy est en quelque sorte
une nouvelle épidémie l'information et
la désinformation se mélangent et le
public et les hommes politiques ne
comprennent pas ce qui se passe j'estime
donc que toutes ces affirmations sont
sans fondement georges on doit faire une
pause
à notre retour nous poursuivons notre
entretien avec le professeur georges
figaro
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour pour poursuivre
notre conversation avec le directeur
général du centre chinois de contrôle
des maladies le professeur georges
fougue à eau
je ne sais pas si tony fauci gardera son
poste ce bail donne mais votre homologue
robert et fields vous a cité dans le
magazine the new yorker le 3 janvier
2020 aucune preuve de transmission entre
humains
c'est ce que vous lui auriez dit au
téléphone the new yorker se trompe ou
robert et de field a mal compris en tant
que directeurs généraux des centres de
contrôle et de prévention des maladies
des deux pays nous continuons un
communiqué et je ne pense pas que
quelqu'un peut en être responsable donc
vous ne lui avait pas dit ça
nous avons eu des discussions détaillées
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit un
sujet que nous avons abordé ce cas ci
c'est semble-t-il à cause de cette
citation que the new yorker a publié et
qu'elle s'est ensuite diffusés voilà le
chef du centre de contrôle des
préventions des maladies chinois qui
donnent des informations erronées à son
collègue américain alors qu'il savait
qu'il avait des preuves
cependant il y avait à l'époque très peu
de preuves de transmission entre humains
du grenat virus vous vous souvenez que
j'ai donné des informations correctes en
dix ans en mars
j'ai été chargée de l'annoncé en mars en
appelant tout le monde en europe et aux
états unis à porter des masques
ça a été publié dans des revues
scientifiques et vous devez vous
rappeler que peu de gens portés alors
des masques il ya beaucoup de rumeurs
beaucoup de désinformation à ce sujet
vous parliez des masques avant même que
l'om est ce conseil de prendre ces
précautions
donnez nous quelques conseils pratiques
je veux dire il y a tellement de
problèmes
la ventilation dans les appartements par
exemple maintenant que nous en apprenons
de plus en plus sur la façon dont les
gouttelettes se propage dans l'air les
gens devraient porter des masques
vous soutenez d'ailleurs le point de vue
du gouvernement britannique sur le
respect de la distanciation de 2 m
puisque vous avez été le premier à
parler de la nécessité de porter des
masques et avait même expliqué pourquoi
la situation pouvait être pire dans les
pays européens et aux états unis en asie
du sud est
quels autres conseils pouvez-vous donner
porter un masque garder ses distances
se laver les mains et surtout continuer
à communiquer de manière ouverte avec
tout le monde en essayant de comprendre
ce qui se passe vous pouvez voir ici en
chine un système de contrôle réussite
après la flambée de one
nous avons eu quelques petites vagues en
chine mais elles sont toutes bien
contrôler pour le moment nous avons
quelques explosions sporadiques en chine
nous travaillons très dur pour les
étouffer mais le monde doit travailler
ensemble
sinon le virus restera actif et il y
aura plus de mutations sur la planète
selon le site de l'université johns
hopkins
le taux de mortalité par habitant en
chine est de 0,33 d'essai pour 100000
habitants pour comparaison les 235 au
royaume uni c'est quasiment comme s'il
n'y avait pas de coronavirus en chine si
on regarde les chiffres est il important
de mettre en place un système de traçage
des malades
le gouvernement britannique a loué des
dizaines de milliards de livres sterling
aux entreprises privées pour le traçage
beaucoup estiment que cela n'a pas
fonctionné c'est pourquoi le royaume uni
fait de la vaccination l'élément
principal de sa stratégie
y at il des raisons d'être inquiet
faut-il avoir un système de traçage
personne n'en parle même plus ici au
royaume uni
même si vous estimez que c'est déjà trop
tard pour le traçage
je crois que si vous travaillez dur
c'est toujours possible pourquoi à mon
avis la chine s'en sort très bien car
dès le début nous avons passé beaucoup
de temps à élaborer au niveau
communautaire
un système de contrôle de la lutte
contre les maladies infectieuses
donc il faut se focaliser sur le niveau
communautaire
parce que la maladie circule au sein de
la communauté
nous avons donc déployé beaucoup
d'efforts dans notre contrôle à ce
niveau là
nous avons quatre niveaux dans le
système du cdc du comté à la préfecture
puis à la province et enfin au niveau
national ces trois niveaux
ils sont tous basés sur le niveau
communautaire en particulier celui des
comptes et beaucoup de gens travaillent
au niveau de la communauté
il y a beaucoup de professionnels ils
ont fait un travail remarquable et ce
sont des personnes clés pour effectuer
le traçage et le suivi cette traque vous
parler de communauté le développement du
capitalisme ici dans les pays de l'otan
consiste à individualiser et à faire en
sorte que l'individu soit le plus
important sans doute au détriment de la
société et de la communauté
voyez vous cela comme un des facteurs
expliquant pourquoi la situation
épidémique est bien pire dans les pays
capitalistes occidentaux
j'estime que ça pourrait être un des
facteurs bien sûr un facteur très très
important chinese le parti communiste
chinois comprend évidemment l'importance
de la coopération mondiale
on nous raconte que les scientifiques
qui ont travaillé pour vous n'avez pas
d'accès internet et que donc il n'était
pas en mesure de coopérer avec d'autres
scientifiques
parce qu'internet a été bloqué à one et
dans d'autres parties de la chine pour
lesquels les scientifiques voulaient
consulter les informations disponibles
en ligne également de la propagande
non en fait j'ai toujours eu accès à
internet
je veux dire qu est ce qu on fait juste
maintenant vous et moi cryptic sommes là
en ligne ce n'est pas coupé nous avons
continué à communiquer non seulement à
l'intérieur du pays mais avec tous nos
collègues à travers le monde pour être
honnête depuis presque un an
tous les jours et toutes les nuits en
raison du décalage horaire je suis en
ligne pour des réunions sur internet
zoom et tous les autres services
alors je ne pense pas que ce soit vrai
vous voyez on est toujours restés en
contact avec tous nos collègues au
royaume uni et aux etats unis
donc si vous êtes un scientifique vous
avez accès aux articles liés à votre
discipline médicale qui ont été
approuvés par vos collègues
parlez moi maintenant de ce qu'on
appelle le coc vie de long une crise de
plus en plus de cas sont signalés au
royaume uni qui est comme gelée déjà dit
le pays du monde le plus touché en
termes de taux de mortalité par habitant
qu'est ce que le coc vinh long
exactement et quelle est son importance
en chine
shine c'est un très bon mot selon
équivaut à peu près à chronique
nous ne voulons pas employer le mot
chronique parce que nous n'avons pas eu
assez de temps pour comprendre à quel
point le coc vite 19 sera un virus à
action lente et chroniques comme je les
dis si l'on se fie au bon sens et aux
connaissances acquises cela ressemble à
une maladie respiratoire aiguë
quand on pense à une maladie
respiratoire aiguë on pense qu'on va se
rétablir totalement
mais ce que nous avons vu avec le co
vite 19 dans le monde entier y compris à
one et au royaume uni
c'est que certains patients lorsqu'ils
ont récupéré ont des symptômes qui
arrivent plus tard certains peuvent
avoir des problèmes de sommeil d'autres
des troubles cardiaques et encore bien
d'autres choses mais on n'a pas eu assez
de temps pour affirmer que la comitis
neuf va être une maladie chronique
il reste que c'est une maladie beaucoup
plus longue d'une maladie respiratoire
aiguë classique et pio et vous constatez
cela en chine
oui nous avons des cas de kovy delon
également c nous avons aussi beaucoup de
cas où des patients rétablissons de
nouveaux infectés mais ce sont là des
questions scientifiques
quel est le pourcentage de cas de covin
l'on adore je n'ai pas les chiffres pour
le nombre des cas mais mes collègues ont
publié un article dans silence est chili
à environ un mois et vous pouvez le
consulter pour obtenir ces informations
à part le kobe de long
espérons que le kobe 19 soit terminée en
chine comment le centre de contrôle des
préventions des maladies
envisage-t-il le problème du changement
climatique pour ce qui est des nouveaux
coronavirus parce que si on parle des
chauves-souris la déforestation a
certainement un rapport avec la
transmission au nautic
oui nous parlons depuis longtemps des
virus au nautic et des maladies
zoonotiques tout le monde veut aborder
la question de la santé mondiale
nous devons combiner les sciences
médicales et vétérinaires agricoles et
environnementales pour surmonter ce
problème
le coc vie de 10,9 en est un bon exemple
ça nous avons besoin que différents
secteurs travaillent ensemble vous savez
ces changements climatiques et
environnementaux pour ont un effet sur
toutes ces maladies infectieuses il
regardait les chauves-souris et rappelez
vous une fois que toutes ces éoliennes
sont apparus leurs pâles tue beaucoup de
chauves souris
c'est un fait établi donc encore une
fois on ne peut pas lutter contre le
coronavirus ou tout autre virus tout
seul
nous devons intégrer toutes ces mesures
et nous attaquer aux problèmes dans le
cadre du concept de santé mondiale kolda
qu attendez vous voulez vous dire que la
question des chauves souris est liée aux
éoliennes
oui mais cela n'a rien à voir avec le
coronavirus non et ça particulièrement
avec le coronavirus mais à cause de ces
grandes pales
elle fuit elles quittent leur habitat
naturel les chauves-souris et beaucoup
d'oiseaux sont tués par les éoliennes
mais personne ne prend vraiment cela au
sérieux
il y a déjà beaucoup de recherches sur
cette question c'est juste un exemple
vous pouvez ainsi détruire l'habitat de
certains animaux sauvages y compris
celui des chauves-souris et cruz la pâte
on pourrait arguer que les combustibles
fossiles utilisés à grande échelle dans
l'agriculture ont un effet plus
considérables que les éoliennes
je vais vous demander de donner quelques
conseils à nos téléspectateurs en europe
occidentale et en amérique qui entendent
des théories du complot selon lesquelles
le coronavirus relèverait de la
fabrication d'armes chinoises ici au
royaume uni le ministre des affaires
étrangères dit que la chine torture les
musulmans ouïghours
il y a beaucoup d'informations
d'accusation de génocide
pourquoi la chine voudrait-elle aider
dans la lutte contre le court aux
navires us si on estime qu'elle est
impliqué dans des meurtres de masse
eh bien mon conseil serait de venir en
chine voir la réalité
ne croyez pas toutes ces rumeurs
venaient tout simplement
g vous aussi venez soyez les bienvenus
et regardez ce qui se passe dans notre
pays ça au pénis l'ouverture la
transparence la collaboration sont la
clé non seulement pour l'europe les
états unis la chine et le reste du monde
mais aussi pour qui que ce soit sur
terre nous vivons dans un village nous
devons travailler ensemble
au début vous m'avez demandé si j'avais
critiqué le vaccin pfizer absolument pas
je n'ai rien dit de mal je dis seulement
qu'il faut être prudent mais le fait que
l'ambassade de chine aux états unis
parlent d'utiliser la science pour
opprimer les gens n'aiment pas beaucoup
ils ont dit l'étude montre que dans le
processus d'éradication de l'extrémisme
l'esprit des femmes louisbourg à xian
zhang a et émancipée et l'égalité des
sexes et la santé reproductive ont été
promus ce qui fait qu'elles ne sont plus
des machines à fabriquer des bébés cela
ne favorise pas la coopération et bien
je ne sais pas de quoi il s'agit je n'ai
jamais entendu parler de ça vous savez
nous devrions tous essayé de comprendre
la science de combattre l'info d'amy et
d'ignorer les rumeurs parce que nous
devons travailler ensemble pour vaincre
le virus et pour le faire disparaître
[Musique]